I'll play something Darcy is probably
great in bed
she's so 90 buddy on 90 day fiancé it
would probably Darcy from out of all the
seat because you know she is wild in bed
and she is probably at a really fun girl
to sleep with not out of every season
even the girls that were more attractive
Darcy looks like she has a ball in the
sash she does but based on dancing I
still and call me a sucker cuz I'm an
old school fan you know I brought this
show to the old show in season one I've
been on board with this thing from
literally the day I'm day one every
thought I was crazy to day one they were
like what this is a girl show I'm like
no it isn't but for me and maybe it's
one of those things like you know when
you grow up and you have a Farrah
Fawcett poster on your on your on your
wall or something like a Pam Anderson
poster on your wall nobody will ever be
hotter than Pam Anderson nobody will
ever take POW as a place for me it's
never gonna happen
season one wow she's the sexiest of all
them without a doubt I mean you look at
her Instagram and she's like - and
workout style it's [ __ ] yeah smoking
hot yeah she might just the hottest but
Darcy just seems like she'll go the she
pal married Russ like they were from
Season one where it was just 90-day
fiance people who had already
established like a lot of those train
wrecks wouldn't even make it to this the
first show no way yeah they were real
relationship right there's a real thing
problems hey it's Oklahoma I'm bored I'm
from Colombia but but but they kind of
had a normal relationship he's a little
too sexy for his family a normal [ __ ]
and that that wouldn't happen now like
they just want disasters before they get
to the [ __ ] country with her workout
videos we follow her Instagram she is
extremely sexy out of this world
yeah just yeah out rages yeah but but
Darcy
I think Darcy would be really fun in bed
I don't know I just got soft and she her
tits look great like she would be really
fun to sleep
she'll [ __ ] you look she won see the
lover yeah she bets right you should
give me [ __ ] you to keep you give you
the old Tyson show [ __ ] you till she
till you love her that's right you think
Troy because you talked about this
sensation before with some of you you've
you've you've made decisions kind of in
a rush sometimes with women that you've
gone to bed with shall we say do you
feel do you feel like immediately after
climax you would look down at Darcy as
Darcy was looking at you lovingly and go
oh no what I just do it's literally it's
the second that come has left the tip
what the [ __ ] did I do and how do I get
out of this yeah because he's looking at
you now like she's gonna marry you and
you've got all that out of your system
and you're going oh no I'm trapped how
do I escape yeah what's the escape route
on this one what do I do
we've all been there we've literally as
the [ __ ] is flying dude you're almost
like I should have had her leave her
shoes outside so when she goes to put
them on I can just close the door
pretend this never happened you're just
sitting there immediately post-coitus
you become walter white in the RV as
uncle Hank is right outside of it
waiting for the warrant to get into it
you're like how the [ __ ] do I get out of
this like lined up and sitting just as
soon as you're finished you just hit go
on and he calls out the uber right
change your phone number to change your
address oh you got caught up yeah that's
exactly right I mean she you know she's
just she will put in that she'll go that
extra mile to make sure you're happy and
she wants you to love her so bad and
then you just have that reality of like
this girl is [ __ ] crazy she's the
type of girl who will ride you and just
lightly play with your nipples and go is
that what you like baby is that what you
like baby she's a fun one Darcy okay are
you speaking for just the Jenner
public or is this more specific than we
realize just saying in general if you
happen to like your girl to do that just
to grind her high knee over your penis
and lightly touch your nipples and go is
that what you want baby nipple play a
little nipple play I can picture drawing
on there's soft lips how good with a
nurse feel oh I mean they'd be they'd be
a blast
pillows yeah I like to write close to
sloppy pillows with tears flown over
what a great Hummer she would give